foreign
[Music]
hello
we have a little bit of a situation we
wanted to run by you Mobius wow great to
see you
see you wow time slipping wait
times you know that yeah you've seen
that yeah can you fix that no
it's impossible to time slipping the TVA
I know but we just saw it happen
yeah
I've been pulled through time
between the past and the present hello
if what I saw is true
there's nothing to stand between this
world and utter destruction only one way
to find out
a little good old-fashioned legwork
listen we have different styles you're a
man of action which is fine
I take a more slow deliberate cerebral
approach
it's really good buy
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
make the hard choice
always have been
always will be
all over the top don't you think I
thought it was spot on
foreign
[Music]